first thing we've got to talk about
today Shawn because otherwise I'll get
it in the neck and so will you for not
nudging me and reminding me
yes everybody I know it this thing here
is still using Windows 7 and the useful
guys at work thanks for doing this chaps
have assured me that the moment this
filming session is finished if I bring
this in they will upgrade that one to
Windows 10 as well we've been talking
about regular expressions basically
about the theory of them and the idea of
them but we've not actually seen them in
practice yeah reg X reg X Ari's they are
a very good illustration of where theory
can me practice but I think in the
previous one we did a little bit of
theory what we ought to do now is just
see them in action I think
a difficult one for me to tackle is this
I think you'll all I'm just trying to
get sympathy here the span of what you
either know or don't know you the
audience is huge on this topic some of
you know way more than I do some of you
really are beginners and struggling to
get used to the somewhat abstract
notation and so on so apologies up front
but this one will seem very simple and
very straightforward to those of you who
have got some expertise but I think it's
important that we regroup and say look
this is the notation we all agree on
this because I have for the future got a
very good example lined up of something
where regular expressions if you like
can only just cope I am doing my
examples here in Lex because I hope that
some of these examples later on will
transfer into being part of a little
compiler of some sort and it's software
I'm used to but it's very
straightforward you give a piece of
regular expression for a pattern you
want to match and then you give if you
like an action that you want to take now
very often having recognized a piece of
regular expression all you want to do is
to echo it back perhaps with a bit of
explanation as to what it means so
here's my simple exercise I'm going to
declare about seven reserved words in my
language but my language is going to
ultimately end up as being an elementary
computer graphics language just like
Brian Kernighan speak so my reserved
words all the things like circus circus
[Music]
circle in fact I should put in both
circle and circus so see if it can
distinguish between the two line arc
spline box that sort of thing I want
those to be picked up as being reserved
words but then if it isn't a reserved
word
my scheme and there's some other bunch
of characters is it a bunch of
characters that would do good service as
being a variable name another as I think
we've said many a time variable names in
many languages follow the pattern that
they must begin with a letter but then
after that they can have any mixer upper
lower case letters and digits in the
name zero or more of them
that's your variable name so reserved
words and named variables of that type
of that particularly reserved word type
that's all we're gonna do today I have
here a Lex script which has got seven
specific lines in for recognizing circle
line arrow spline box arc or bonus at
the bottom circus star see IRC so when
you look at it it see it's either gonna
match that or that or that or that's all
that the reserved words if it won't
match any of those it keeps coming down
trying to match try to use the next
regular expression to get a match and
below here I just give zero to nine it
says in square brackets plus and that's
a piece of regular expression notation
that says any combination of digits
naught to nine in any order going on
arbitrarily long for the moment here
those a to Zed or a to Zed choices it
means anything in that range literally
those characters in however many
combinations are possible so I've put
all this together I fed it intellect a
compiled it all that for you and won't
bore you by doing it in front of you but
believe me I have saved this as a binary
executable it's called test re for test
regular expression but it only handles
these regular expressions I think we're
all ready to go I just type in the name
of the executable binary test re let's
see if it works right
silence signifies are unhappy yes is
waiting so go on tell me something just
try
let's use the name Bob Bob you just want
Bob all on its own Bob okay
what will Bob do would you agree with
that Bob is a variable name in other
words it's a valid identifier for a
variable of some sort fine yes yeah
there's nothing to stop you calling your
integers or your circles or your lines
you can call them Bob if you want to
that's fine this is I'm saying that this
thing as advertised really does treat
words like circle and line as being
special let's see if it filters those
out and gets it right so I'll just say
circle on its own lowercase look at that
as part of my pattern matching circle is
one of my entries in reserved words that
must be recognized just as is lowercase
notice and it's worked it basically says
yeah got you circle it's a reserved word
and just to emphasize I haven't got it
it's alright now this time I'm spelling
it with a capital C and my guess my hope
is that it will recognize the first
circle as being a reserved word the
second circle can't be a reserved word
because it's case sensitive right it's
circle all lowercase has been reserved
but the version with an uppercase C
isn't us therefore who knows he should
be a variable let's see if that works
yeah Circle all lowercase is reserved
echo it back just to be sure yeah I got
it it's circle but circle is a variable
name which I think sounds right I think
of something else that might break it
Sean God well we talked earlier and you
kind of said the idea of putting the
word circus in there to throw it because
it's so similar yes that's a good point
let's just try Circus is happy with that
I did make it a reserved word but it
hasn't sort of come up with all I can't
decide between circle and circus part of
what I was saying in the episode last
time is that one of Lex's jobs is to say
despite the fact that circle and circus
have a common beginning and very clever
and I
very efficiently factorize that
beginning out and then say well after
that if it ends le it's a reserved word
if it turns us it's also a reserved word
but it's happy so a good thing to do now
I think would be can you name a circus
yeah
[Music]
better still perhaps how about this I
want to name another circus but I'm
gonna call it a circus one now that
should be no problem because it's not
saying circus circus it's saying circus
reserved word and that category circus
one can only be a variable name so it's
using the space to delineate yes the way
I've got it set up at the moment is I
haven't told it to ignore spaces yes
I've left the main because it it serves
in the world wonders at the moment is a
very handy break between these various
things which can then be analyzed
separately this then is if you like
aligning with the history of Lex and
regular expressions is that Mike let's
put them in this front end to enable you
to do reserved words variables all sorts
of things like that but historically
they then migrated out into things that
have nothing to do with compilers many
of you will have heard of UNIX awk and
that was the great granddaddy of all
sorts of things that you're more
familiar with like Perl PHP Python and
so on August characteristic was they
just did reg X pattern matches then
actions there was no context it was
interpretive ork you gave it the thing
to do it comes straight back at you you
didn't have to recompile it every time
so here's the first beginnings and what
we need for a longer example we've got
the ability to take a of characters in
any combination zero or more of two
named variables fixed sets of characters
of certain variety like circle line box
are dealt with first so I think the
thing to take away from this is that in
programs like orc and legs you've got to
remember that the various possibilities
you give will be done in that
order its you've got to imagine that
between the lines there's almost an or
operation you start up at the top you
say it will either my match circle or it
will match box or it will match line or
it will match spline or it will match
arrow and so it goes on and then down at
the bottom the catch-all is and if it
doesn't match any of those let's just
see if it could be a legal variable and
then you just run out and I have to
accept this if you put in a line of
punctuation I think it would just
activate backup me and not do anything
with it let's just see quote pounds doll
it just echoes back it takes no action
just says me I don't know what that is I
think this has set us up now I hope into
being able to do a longer example than
this but to me at least regular
expressions come into their own for this
kind of thing one liners to name things
you know match a pattern do that with it
all over one line they're not all that
well suited to doing very long range big
strategic structure so many of you have
said to me Oh cover why reg X's can't do
XML properly well I might get onto that
but yes you know you all know XML has
got big tree like structure reg X's do
not of themselves find it easy to do
though can I ask one question if you had
a real circus what would it called would
it be like the great Brill's for Dini
wasn't there a Circus Maximus in Rome
no there we go I just think he needs a
bit more of a showman's title in dance
Oh Barnum & Bailey is that right do you
want me to try Barnum & Bailey